hey 42 here in the southwest of China's
Sichuan province sits a small village
called Italia where the local
schoolchildren must climb an 800 meter
bamboo ladder at the sight of a sheer
cliff face just to get to school the
only skill for many miles around sits
atop this rocky outcrop there are no
roads or pathways to the top only this
ladder I bet your journey to school
seems incredibly benign in comparison
now you may not have to scale a cliff
face to attend school but the education
you receive every day or did once
receive it's just as precarious and
insufficient education is broke over the
past 50 years the world has changed
beyond recognition yet the school
systems in most countries have stayed
static our current education systems
were designed and built in the
industrial age in some countries that's
as long ago as the 18th century sure
there have been many subtle changes over
the decades but the basic goal of our
school systems has remained exactly the
same for over 200 years and what is that
goal to produce obedient factory workers
during the industrial era and right up
to the epoch of the 21st century most
people worked in manufacturing whether
it was on production lines on farms or
in mines where things like creativity
and individuality only get in the way of
profits factory owners needed obedient
droned in large numbers and so many
wealthy business owners invested large
sums of money into lobbying to influence
politicians to shape the school systems
in the ideologies of said factory owners
putting values such as order and
discipline as top priority and making
sure that creativity and individualism
were quashed such lobbying happened
mostly in America but nevertheless the
school systems in most developed
countries today are still built on the
robotic unstable by ologies and so kids
today arrived at school nice and early
not a minute too late we are ordered to
sit down in our pre designated seats
because god only knows what was a chaos
would unravel if we were to sit where we
pleased we are programmed to respond to
a series of bells and whistles that
signify when we are allowed to eat and
leave we have to ask permission to speak
to move to go to the bathroom this used
to be kind of okay because this forced
obedience would carry over to the
factory for which is where most people
ended up anyway right after school but
today and for quite some time now we
have been living in a world where most
people can do whatever they desire for a
career if they try hard enough I mean
you can actually be a professional
bed-warmer a pet food taster or a raven
master yes these are all real jobs the
nature of jobs has changed drastically
and today we live in a world where
qualities such as creativity
individualism and entrepreneurial ism
are highly sought after by a lot of
employers let me ask you a question how
come if you're bad at English maths or
science you repeatedly told you're not
trying hard enough your work is
scrutinized your parents are notified of
your poor performance you're made to
resit tests until you get it right yes
if you're bad at art music or sport
you're simply told don't worry it's just
not your thing despite these all being
just as valid career choices
the huge fact of life that modern school
systems ignore is that everyone has
their own unique talents and things that
they are really passionate about we're
all naturally good at something and
terrible at other things whether that's
because of our genetics or our
upbringing some children are just more
creative whilst others are more academic
we're all unique Albert Einstein
supposedly wrote everybody is a genius
but if you judge a fish by its ability
to climb a tree it will live it's whole
life believing that it is stupid the
human brains ability and desire to learn
is astonishing and yet it is possible
for almost anyone to learn anything I'm
not saying that every child shouldn't
learn mathematics because every child
can but where most school systems fail
is in bringing out the best in every
child and encouraging exploration of
their natural abilities what the really
stupid thing is that schools don't even
do a decent job of teaching English
maths and science in fact they do a
rather terrible job indeed public
education today but is based on a system
of taking a bunch of information and
systematically reciting that information
to the students whom are later tested on
their ability to remember that
information and the key point here is
that exams only test a child's ability
to remember so week before your exam you
would recite the same textbook
information over and over again
until you had near enough the entire
textbook memorized but what happens
after the exam you forget it all
multiple studies have shown that
children and adults forget 95% of
everything that they memorize after just
three days so an a-star test score says
know more about a child and their
ability to recite information it is not
a strongly correlated representation of
actual intelligence that is the ability
to acquire new skills of one's very own
accord this process of phoning via
memorization is known as inauthentic
learning because you aren't actually
learning only regurgitating information
and anyone can do that it's what I do
for a living so you are
how does one learn authentically how do
we actually teach kids instead of asking
them to memorize
well we quite simply have to spark their
curiosity
humans are unquenchable curious as
toddlers we have to touch everything we
see stick our fingers in to plug sockets
and dismantle everything that curiosity
never leaves us it's hopefully what I
you watch my videos when you allow
children to become curious about
something they will actually teach
themselves because they have a primal
desire to find out as much as they can
and the best part about the self
curiosity driven learning is it is
completely authentic and children will
absorb that knowledge like a sponge and
most importantly you can be sure they
will remember it because when we are
engaged we are happy and our brains
naturally remember the times when we are
happy a great number of the world's
greatest fingers its greatest
entrepreneurs and history's greatest
leaders all share something in common
they dropped out of school names such as
Richard Branson Quentin Tarantino Mark
Zuckerberg Steve Jobs Bill Gates F scott
Fitzgerald John Lennon Walt Disney Tom
Hanks Coco Chanel Benjamin Franklin
Albert Einstein Charles Dickens and
Princess Diana every single one of these
successful and highly influential
individuals dropped out of school
between the ages of 11 and 16 now I'm
not promoting dropping out of school but
simply illustrating equality that all of
these people have in common they were
incredibly passionate and curious about
one particular thing that interested
them do you really think that they would
have dropped out of education if their
skills supported their true passion no
these people all felt the same way as
many young people do today that school
was only holding them back slowing them
luckily these people are able to follow
their passions regardless of their
education but sadly millions of children
aren't many young people could unlock
their true patterns if the education
industry focused on what they do best
instead of everything that they're not
good at but thankfully today you can
fulfill your own curiosity thanks to
technology we are now able to learn
anything we desire
we've unlimited invaluable information
at our fingertips self education and
discovery site such as Skillshare enable
you to fulfill your first for becoming a
better you wear traditional education
has failed you skill sure is an online
learning platform with more than 17,000
classes in design photo and much more I
personally dropped out of college I
instead used the incredible resources
available on the internet to teach
myself the skills I needed to do what I
love and in doing so I have been able to
fulfill my passion of making videos and
teaching others about incredible things
YouTube is my career and I'm so very
grateful that today we don't have to
rely on outdated traditional education
systems to follow our passions using
Skillshare you can follow your passions
and turn doing whatever it is you love
doing into a career a premium Skillshare
membership gives you unlimited access to
thousands of classes from leading
experts all around the world so you can
learn from the very best and unlock your
true potential in the comfort of your
own home if you have a passion that you
would love to turn into a career then
incredible skill share courses such as
art of the starts turning ideas into
high-growth businesses are a great place
to start since skill share is sponsoring
this video the first 500 people to use
the promo link in the description below
will get their first two months
completely free to try it out risk-free
after two months it's only $10 a month
to watch unlimited classes but with two
months free you have nothing to lose and
you could look back in a year's time
when your hobby has
come your career and be so thankful that
you did now there is another fundamental
problem were school today and it's not
to do with what goes on in the classroom
I'm talking about sleep when you start a
job it generally accepted that you will
turn up at 9:00 a.m. or earlier every
morning and this same time expectation
is put upon school kids all the way from
primary school to high school college
and university what there's a
deep-rooted biological issue with that
which explains why when I was at school
I spent at least thirty percent of my
lessons asleep at my desk our bodies are
phenomenal timekeepers and our
subconscious is often well aware of the
current time even if your conscious mind
isn't you know how sometimes you wake up
exactly one minute before your alarm
clock this is because of your body's
circadian rhythm this is our internal
clock and it also determines when it is
the best time for us to fall asleep
until wakeup but our circadian rhythm
varies throughout our lives when we are
younger than ten our bodies want to wake
up as early as possible but it soon gets
later and later throughout adolescence
between the ages of 14 and 24 our
circadian rhythm is set at the latest it
will ever be throughout our lives and
our natural desire is to wake up later
in the morning for example after 10:00
a.m. there's nothing we can do to fight
this biological urge recent studies have
shown that forcing teenage students to
wake up before 7 a.m. to attend school
between 8 a.m. and 9 a.m. plays havoc
with our body's intended sleep cycle the
result is that teenagers get fall asleep
throughout these critical years and
concentration in the classroom takes a
steep dive into the sleepy abyss there
is absolutely no scientific evidence
that starting school any earlier than
10:00 or 11:00 a.m. is beneficial to
learning quite the opposite in fact
thankfully this at least is changing
over the past couple of years in Britain
as part of a large experiment from the
by a London charity hundreds of schools
across the UK are being asked to shift
their school days forward in our water
and asking students to arrive at 10 a.m.
instead this experiment is still ongoing
today but early indications from this
large-scale test have already shown that
schoolchildren across the country are
happier more engaged learning more and
the rising rates of mental illness
amongst teenagers which has been
partially attributed to sleep
deprivation are starting to plateau
there is one country that has taken
changing the entire school system into
their very own hands and made changes so
sweeping that the way they do school is
completely unrecognizable to most of us
and as a result this country now has the
most successful school system in the
entire world welcome to Finland over the
years multiple studies have ranked
Finland as the most successful and most
efficient school system in the world and
they ranked number two globally for
science and number three for reading but
what does Finland's do so differently to
say the u.s. which consistently ranks
down in the mid 40s for efficiency
America also ranked number 33 in science
and number seventeen in reading well for
a start children in Finland don't even
start school until the age of seven
compared to the normal age of five in
most countries allowing them far more
time to just be children and for the
first six years of a child's education
in Finland they are not measured in any
way it literally doesn't matter how they
perform in class because seriously what
is the point of testing a ten-year-old
when all they really want to do is paint
on walls and lick trees in fact there is
only one just one standardized test
during the entirety of a child's
education in Finland and it's not taken
until they're at least 16 years old on
that exam isn't even at
per say it's used to find out which
students need more individual help than
the others homework is far less common
and they don't begin to actually issue
homework until students are well into
their teen years in fact Finnish kids
spend the least time on homework per
week than any country in the world as an
average of just over two hours per week
compared to six hours per week for the
average American pupil the finished
school day is far shorter than other
countries they typically start at 9:00
a.m. and finish school between 1:00 and
2:00 p.m. teachers in Finland only work
for a maximum of four hours each day and
they put aside two hours each week for
professional development helping them to
become better teachers one of the
biggest differences between Finnish and
American schools is the amount of free
time that students are permitted in
Finland students get a 15-minute break
after every single lesson the average
daily break time of a Finnish school
students is a whopping 75 minutes
compared to just 27 minutes for an
American student recent studies have
conclusively shown that more break time
relative to class time actually
increases test scores and learning and
decreases mental illness depression and
general bad behavior among school
children quite simply a happy and
healthy child is going to be less bored
and more engaged so how do Finland do
when it comes to encouraging every
child's unique abilities like I was
talking about earlier remarkably well
actually Finnish school pupils have 25
lessons a week and nine of those are
arts crafts music and sports that's
almost 40 percent of lessons also the
National Curriculum in Finland is just a
set of broad guidelines rather than a
strict checklist that has to be a here
to the individual teachers have a lot
more power to tailor their lessons to
suit their students children aren't
segregated into different classes
depending on their intelligence
or historic test scores the classes are
kept small but children that need extra
help had given huge amounts of
one-on-one attention to help get them up
to speed and the results show that the
gap between the worst performing kids
and the highest performers in Finland is
the smallest in the world in Finland no
child is left behind but it's actually
true over there rather than just an
empty political slogan in Finland the
high school dropout rate of students is
a tiny 0.4% in America it is 25 percent
that's millions of students per year by
far one of the highest in the developed
world America also has one of the
largest gaps between the test scores of
the rich than the poor but a lot of
experts argue that you couldn't simply
take the blueprint for the Finnish
school system and implement it overnight
in America for one major reason the two
countries are culturally economically
and socially so very very different for
a start the cultural differences are
enormous take religion in the u.s. 22
percent of the population are
religiously unaffiliated with just 3%
categorizing themselves as atheists
whereas in Finland an impressive 60
percent of the country are religiously
unaffiliated or non-believers and 22
percent are atheists almost everyone in
Finland is middle class they have one of
the smallest gaps in the world between
the rich and the poor this allows for a
stable and consistent publicly funded
school system across the entire culture
whereas America has the biggest wealth
inequality of any developed country in
the world this creates huge problems
we're balancing the school system from
state to state and district to district
in America the gap between the quality
of education in poor areas and wealthy
areas is enormous to integrate the
Finnish system into American schools the
whole economics of the school system
would have to be turned on its head
as well as schools in states constantly
competing against each other to get the
best test scores and get the most
funding American teachers get paid merit
pay a top up of their salary of their
students perform well in standardized
tests causing teachers to push their
students beyond reasonable levels to
achieve higher test scores with no
regards to whether they are genuinely
and authentically learning merit pay
does not exist in Finland
neither does competition between schools
children in Finland and most countries
for that matter can go to school without
the fear of violence the statistics show
that in the u.s. 27 percent of students
have carried a dangerous weapon to
school 10 percent have carried a gun to
school and 40 percent have been in a
physical fight whilst at school now I'm
not here to endlessly praise Finland or
to point fingers at America or any other
school system for that matter
but proper education is so unbelievably
important to society as it is quite
literally our future the children of
today will be the scientists doctors
lawyers and politicians of tomorrow
economists predict that improving the
education system in the US would boost
the US economy by 27 trillion dollars
over the next few decades similarly in
the UK economists predict that there is
much room for improvement in our school
system - and doing so would boost our
economy by three point six trillion
pounds improving education would mean a
better safer and more sustainable world
for everyone yes we need to take
inspiration from Finland and over
education leading countries but first we
need to take inspiration from their
attitude towards society and towards
life thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video then please click here to
support me on patreon click here to
watch another video and don't forget to
subscribe also don't forget to check out
the link in a description for two months
of Skillshare for free